hi I'm Daniel Josh I'm a PhD student at
the University of Illinois and I work at
the National Center for supercomputing
applications so my talk will be about
deep learning for time series signal
processing in the context of
gravitational wave analysis especially
like Oh so I will show how to design and
train a neural network in the world from
language and how to use pre trained
models to classify anomalies in noisy
data streams from the LIGO detectors
so I'll be talking about three projects
that I did using the Wolfram language
are related to gravitational wave
analysis for LIGO so this is work that
was done at NCSA recently and I'll get
started now with the first project so
first of all to give you a brief
overview gravitational waves are these
ripples in the fabric of space and time
they're predicted by Einstein in 1916
and we actually detected this for the
first time in 2016 exactly 100 years
later so you can see that been really
massive and dense objects like black
holes and neutron stars they spiral in
and merge they release these waves that
we can actually even measure billions of
light-years away using detectors such as
LIGO which is laser interferometry and
this is how the gravitational wave
signal looks like when a pair of black
holes merge and these are the two
detectors that we have right now in the
two opposite corners of the United
States there's one more in Europe
it's called Virgo it just started
running recently and there are more
coming up soon so the we are actually
detected for black hole mergers so far
one of them is is likely to be a false
detection so we're not sure about the
second one but we have four detections
that are called three detections that
are confirmed and last week the Nobel
Prize was awarded to keep tendre wise
and very bearish for leading the LIGO
collaboration and then on this Monday we
actually announced that we detected a
pair of neutron stars merging for the
first time and what's special about this
is that we can actually detect light
from this event unlike when black holes
merge it only emits gravitational waves
whereas neutron stars actually emit
light all the way from gamma rays to
radio and we actually observed this with
70 telescopes and this leads to
groundbreaking insights and physics but
the challenge that we are facing right
now is that signals are really weak most
of the signals are have a
signal-to-noise ratio less than one so
you can actually see them in the time
series or and the spectrograms so this
is actually how it should look like so
these signals are buried in noise and
how do you detect signals that are so
weak so one
advantage we have is that we can solve
these physical events on supercomputers
like blue waters which is like right
next door and we know what gravitational
waves should look like so we can
actually try using a template matching
method so it's basically a
classification and regression problem
you have some input data and you want to
find what is it in it so you know
classify it as a signal or noise and you
want to measure what the masses of the
black holes are and what the masses of
the neutron star are exit exit or like
supernova so what they do right now is
they have a huge bang of these
simulations so you can imagine it's like
calendar photos you're looking for cats
and dogs in your data so you have this
huge album of simulations of cats and
dogs or gravitational waves and then you
try comparing every input with every
data that you get from your detectors
and you see if there's an exact match
and this is not at all scalable you
can't you need bit trillions of
simulations to actually do this kind of
analysis so this is what is going on
right now so they're only looking at a
small subset of signals so what we want
to do is to scale this to all possible
signals and the solution is of course
deep learning so the idea behind deep
learning is you stack a bunch of neurons
a bunch of layers together and these
very deep network of neurons actually
are very good at learning patterns in
the data so you don't actually need to
keep all these templates and compare
inputs one by one
instead you can train a network and it
generalizes to the full space of signals
from a limited amount of data and this
is very successful from all areas
including speech recognition face
recognition self-driving cars all kinds
of things so these are some applications
that are happening right now so you can
see it's being used in medical diagnoses
and these captions are actually
generated by a neural network and it's
really accurate and for example when
Facebook tags your photos it's using a
neural network and Google assistant Siri
etc so yeah the basic idea behind neural
networks is you start off with a bunch
of neurons and you set it with random
weights and then you I creatively tune
the weight so that the error
on your training data is minimized so
it's basically an optimization problem
you have some label data and you want to
fit the weight such that it the error on
data surface is that a minima so you are
at the minimum and data surface and what
we are using here is called a
convolutional neural network and it's
commonly used for image recognition you
can see that since about 2015 it's more
accurate than humans at classifying
images basically the image net data set
is a bunch of labeled real-world photos
and each layer actually learns
hierarchically different simple features
and they combine it to create the final
input so this is actually much more
efficient than doing template matching
so here what we did is we use a
convolution neural network for doing a
1d with 1d input so it's more commonly
is used for images in video but here we
applied it to 1d time series data and we
use data from LIGO detectors and there
is a lot of advantages of doing this
because you have architectures like GPUs
and FPGA which a very efficient so you
can do the analysis in real time on site
instead of doing this on a cluster of
hundreds of thousands of GPUs or CPUs
that is that they're using right now and
these neural networks are only a few
megabytes whereas the template bank that
is used to train it was like gigabytes
of data and the most important advantage
is that you can interpolate to templates
between your training data whereas the
current templating master template
matching methods can only find the
templates in the bank sync so the signal
should match exactly so this is a huge
advantage we use we start with very
simple convolution neural networks you
can see there's three convolution layers
this is in the Wolfram language and a
couple of fully connected layers and we
have two neural networks the first one
tells you whether there's a signal or
not and the second one if the first one
says yes then you apply the second
Network and it will tell you the masses
of the black holes that produce the
signal so you can actually I can
actually show you the code to do this in
the Wolfram language so basically you
just get some training data then you
make a function that generates training
data like this so you it has a data so
you have noise you have signal and then
labeled this as false and this is true
and then you train this net which is a
very simple so it's just a few lines of
code and this is the network and here
you have the training so when I actually
did this I did not know anything about
machine learning or neural networks at
all all I knew red was the documentation
so I did it's the moment that this
functionality came out and then I wrote
I I got the results and then while I was
writing the paper I had to actually
understand how all this works to write
the introduction but so this I did like
back in December so yeah so you can see
the error going down with iterations and
then you can stop it let's see so now
you're testing it on a test set so
you're adding Gaussian noise to a signal
and you're seeing if it works and it
says true and then if you input just
pure Gaussian noise it says false so
even which is like five seconds of
training it's already working and then
you can also do the same thing for
estimating the masses I'm not showing
that it's the same things of labeling
true and false you label it with the
numbers of the black hole masses and
this is the comparison with the current
method which is called match filtering
so on the same CPU the neural network is
like 100 times faster at doing this
detection and parameter estimation if
you actually use the GPU it's over 5,000
times faster which is a huge improvement
this means that you can analyze the data
as it's coming from the detectors and
even thousands of thousands of seconds
of data can be processed in less than
one second on achieve GPU like a gaming
GPU and we actually actually compared
with all the other methods and the
classify function in mathematics and you
can see that the neural network is much
much better for both detecting the
signal and also for estimating the
masses so 50% accuracy here means it's
just randomly guessing so for these
noisy signals the traditional machine
learning methods don't work at all and
now we actually train this with real
LIGO data and you can see there's all
kinds of glitches and the
tech programs even so it's not just pure
Gaussian noise but we found that it
still works for real data even though we
only trained it on Gaussian noise so
this is a comparison on how many what
percentage of signals are detected worse
is the optimal signal-to-noise ratio you
can see that it's almost the same as the
current method that they use for the
signals that we train because we use the
same template bank but for estimating
the masses the neural networks are much
more accurate because they can
interpolate to regions within the
template bag and one additional
advantage is that if the deep learning
method is resilient to all kinds of
anomalies that show up in the data which
are not signals it just glitches in the
detectors so the network can
automatically recognize the difference
between these and the signals and
finally if you actually have a period of
bad quality data and a signal happens to
occur during this data the neural
network can still detected with over 80
percent sensitivity or accuracy which is
not these signals would be currently
missed by the techniques that LIGO uses
now because whenever there's a region of
bad quality that data's removed so this
means that we can detect signals that
could have not been found yet but we
haven't yet applied this to all the LIGO
data so far and here I have have a demo
so I'm showing it's not playing supposed
to play
so this shows the first gravitational
wave event and you can actually slide
the neural network through the event and
when it reaches the signal tells you the
masses and it tells that the
gravitational wave was detected so this
is so fast that you can actually even
run it on your graph on your GPU on a
laptop or even on your laptop CPU
whereas the car for actually detecting
this they use hundreds of thousands of
CPU hours for doing the full parameter
estimation all right then and another
advantage is that we only trained with
black holes on circular orbits but the
network is still able to detect these
weird signals that happen to occur from
black holes on elliptic orbits and the
current methods always missed these
because they don't use these templates
so this means that the network in
generalized two new kinds of events that
would become missed by current methods
okay and this is the second project that
we did recently here we want to actually
find anomalies in the data set there we
don't have any models so you don't know
what you're looking for so how do you
find events like these so here what we
do is we use transfer learning so you
have these data sets of all kinds of
weird anomalies in the LIGO data and
it's been labeled by humans so we have a
small data set of around 6,000 images
like these hand labelled by humans and
we want to don't train a network usually
you need like hundreds of thousands of
input data to train on your network but
if you use this approach called transfer
learning where you train a network on
real world objects of like cats and dogs
and planes and things like that and then
you can fine tune that network on your
data set so it can learn from a small
amount of data this is exactly why
humans are good at learning really fast
because they already have a model of the
real world internally so for this we use
a network trained on image net which is
a huge data set of millions of images
it's actually being used by image
identify actually larger data set is
used by image identify so we used a
model called inception
and after this five minutes of training
we got state-of-the-art results we've
got over about 99% accuracy whereas the
previous work done by another group was
around 96% and they had to train for
hours so I can actually show you the
code to do this it's actually just a few
lines and the Wolfram language so what
you want is to first get your data set
so this is what it looks like just a
bunch of images labeled with 22 classes
these are the 22 classes and then you
get a net model you get a pre trained
net from the neural net repository so
this is one of the state of that net it
small inception b3 so it's only designed
for thousand classes of like real world
objects oops okay anyway so now we need
to change the number of classes to 22
because that's this number of classes in
our data set so you actually take up to
the fourth last layer and then you
attach 22 neurons to the last layer and
then you add a soft max layer so it's
kind of simple so now you have a new net
with pre-trained weights designed to
classify 22 classes of objects and then
you fine-tune it by training this
modified net on your data set for just
like five minutes you usually need a GPU
to do this because its net is a giant
neural net and once that's done I'm just
going to stop the training here because
I don't have a GPU
okay and then once you have this net it
is very accurate we got 99% accuracy at
finding these signals so these are
spectrograms of LIGO data and we can
classify them into these 22 classes with
99% accuracy and all right so this is a
classifier now we can also use these
classifiers to find unknown unlabeled
classes of objects so this is called a
clustering and here what we do is we
once you train this neural network you
can cut off its last layer and use it as
a feature extractor so it converts an
image into a bunch of numbers that
capture some meaning about the input
image so once you have this truncated
convolutional neural network you can
then use it to project new kinds of new
images into different points and some
high dimensional space so here I'm using
the dimension reduce function in
Mathematica in the Wolfram language to
project this into 3d so you can see the
different known classes occur in
different parts of the space now suppose
a new class which it has never seen this
is a class that we don't know about so
I'm just simulating a reverse sharp
shape signal so if this occurs you can
actually find that these signals are all
clustered in this region of parameter
space so using this unsupervised
clustering technique you can find new
kinds of objects which we there are no
labels for by just looking at this
projections and then you can use that
feature extractor and the feature space
plot function to just group together all
kinds of similar looking signals and the
LIGO data stream so to do that it's
actually very easy so you want you you
have this pre trained net now you again
cut off its last layer so you just take
up to the fourth last layer so now you
have this net which takes an image as
input and projects it into 2048 numbers
and then you can so these are all the
unknown classes in the test set
so these are the positions of the
unknown classes in the test set see
there's none of the above and now you
use features based plot with this
feature extractor and you get so this
net was not actually trained if you
actually trained it you find groups of
clusters in different parts of the 2d
space so this is a automatic way to find
objects that you don't know about so
this actually shows you how different
these are all similar looking types of
signals alright so the next thing that
we are doing is called
denoising where you have input data so
you have input data which is very noisy
and you want to just remove the noise
and see the clean signal inside it so
this is what we actually are doing right
now
so he used a recurrent neural network
which is designed for taking sequences
of inputs and producing sequences of
inputs as a sequence of outputs so it's
commonly used for translation voice
recognition handwriting recognition etc
so you can do anything from one to one
many to many all kinds of combinations
are possible so this is really powerful
what we used is something called a long
short-term memory unit which is actually
available in the Wolfram language since
version 11.10 many-to-many model and we
have an encoder which compresses and
input time series into just a bunch of
numbers called a thought vector and then
we have a decoder that tries to
reproduce a clean signal from this set
of numbers so it's called a denoising
auto-encoder because you have noisy
input as noisy signals as the input and
the clean signals as the output so it's
trying to just reproduce what is there
in the input without the noise
so it's an encoder auto encoder and
these are always cells so this is the
current state-of-the-art method where
they use something called dictionary
learning and you can see that the at
this high signal-to-noise ratio their
inputs are not exactly matching whereas
our method is actually matching
perfectly and when there is a signal and
then there is no signal you just get a
flat output so you can actually see in
time what signals are there in your
highly noisy data streams and the only
trained is on Gaussian noise and then we
applied it to real noise and magically
it somehow work for real like Oh noise
as well without with zero amount of
training you can see that it's matching
perfectly almost unto the end so if you
actually did use real noise for training
me expect the results would be much
better and when there is no signal it's
a flat line and then you input these
eccentric elliptical orbits you actually
still get pretty good accuracy even
though the networks have never seen this
so it's a really powerful model so now
what we want to do is to apply all these
real-time analysis techniques so that we
can come the moment that you find an
even like a binary neutron star merger
with gravitational waves you can then
look at the object with telescopes such
as the dark energy survey the large
synoptic scale scope that's coming up
and also with Astro particle detectors
like the Ice Cube which is a neutrino
detector and once you combine all this
immediately you can actually get new
scientific insights that is right now it
took almost ten to twelve hours to see
this event after we detected the
gravitational wave so now our group is
actually applying deep learning to all
parts of this scenario where we are
already applying it to gravitational
wave detection now we are also applying
it to telescopes they're using 2d
convolution neural networks to find
transient objects and telescope data so
all you have a huge group at NCSA which
is working on this right now with over
40 people so that is it is there any
questions
[Applause]
you